le film base l'éclair est interdit dans
plusieurs pays voici pourquoi en fait
pour la première fois pixar intègre une
scène de baiser entre deux personnes du
même sexe dans 22 c'est filmé la
séquence dérange aux émirats arabes unis
et en arabie saoudite et du coup le film
ne sera pas projeté dans ces pays cette
scène avait déjà fait polémique il ya
quelques mois elle avait été retirée par
disney mais des employés de pixar
s'était indigné de cette décision ils
dénonçaient la censure de nombreux
contenus lgbt cuillé a plus qui se
retrouvait souvent coupées au montage
final dans d'autres films du studio face
à la pression disney avait finalement
réintégré la scène du baiser au film
base des clercs rejoint la longue liste
de films censurés aux émirats arabes
unis et en arabie saoudite c'était déjà
le cas pour dr klein jeans multiverse of
madness ou encore west side story de
steven spielberg même si les émirats
arabes unis adoptent progressivement des
réformes sociales présenté comme plus
libéral lohan jam rights watch a accusé
la semaine dernière les autorités de
criminaliser des actes vague comme tout
comportement qui offense la pudeur et la
morale publique et qui incite à une vie
de péché